hello everyone in this video we'll talk
about
leukotrienes this small concept of
biochemistry
is kind of confusing to many of you but
after this video i promise that this
concept would be super duper clear to
you
let's analyze the name to understand the
concept leuko
is kind of similar to leukocytes it's
kind of associated with leukocytes
so by looking at the name we understand
there is something to do with leukocytes
then trines kind of tell us about some
chemical features that there are three
consecutive double bonds
so now we understand leukotrienes are
kind of some chemical
molecules which might have a chemical
feature of three consecutive double
bonds and they're
found in leukocytes so these
leukocytes these leukotrienes are
actually a family of echosanoid and
they're arachidonic acid derivative
glucotrienes are inflammatory mediators
just like other arachidonic acid
derivative
such as prostaglandins so let's talk
about
how leukotrienes are synthesized in our
body
so everything starts with the
arachitonic acid
and i am damn sure that you know how
arachidonic acid is synthesized it's
from the plasma
membrane phospholipids by the action of
a specific phospholipids enzymes
now arachidonic acid gets converted to
leukotrienes
and the key enzyme in this process is
arachidonate
5 lipoxygenes and 5 lipoxygenes enzyme
is the great limiting enzyme here so
this
could be used as a target for several
diseases now leukotrienes
are generated by oxidation of archetonic
acid
so if you look at the pathway here we
can see arachidonic acid
is oxidized into an intermediate which
is known as
5 hp ete and then ultimately it gets
converted to liquid trine a4
from liquid trine a4 they are further
converted to leukotriene
b4 and c4 and the t enzyme that we have
to understand in this pathway
is arachidonate 5 lipoxygenes
and here we can see if we look at this
position we can see there are oxygen
association with the ring that means
oxidation had happened
now let me tell you that leukotrienes
are lipid
lipid-based signaling molecules which
can convey
paracrine and autocrine mode of
signaling and they are generally
pretty much common in case of immune
systems
so they could either give rise to
autocrine signaling or they can give
rise to
paracrine signaling in between
leukocytes
now the production of leukotriene is
usually accompanied with the production
of prostaglandins
and histamines which are other
inflammatory mediators so from
arachidonic acid
one hand side there could be production
of leukotriene and other hand side there
could be also production of
prostaglandin prostaglandin derivatives
which are
also take part in inflammatory responses
okay since we have learned the structure
of the leukotrienes now let's understand
how leukotriene signaling works and how
it can work like a signaling molecule
so leukotriene receptors are class of g
protein coupled receptor
so generally they work by elevation of
the cyclic amp in the cell
and lead to several pro-inflammatory
cytokine genes
etc but few liquid receptors are also
nuclear receptor type or ppar receptor
type
and these receptors are generally found
in eosinophils endothelial cells mass
cells etc
now since these are found in endothelial
cells and also smooth muscle cells
they are having important role in terms
of smooth muscle contraction
and that connects their physiological
role with disease
so let's try to understand how
leukotriene is associated with disease
so major role of leukotriene especially
leukotriene d4 is to trigger
contraction of bronchioles
so contraction of the bronchioles is
triggered by leukotriene
and this is the key underlying feature
of rhinitis
or asthma-like diseases now leukotrienes
contribute to
pathophysiology of asthma as well as
especially in the case of aspirin
exhibited respiratory diseases
whose symptoms are air flow obstruction
increase secretion of mucus
bronch constriction infiltration of the
inflammatory cells
etc now excess of leukotrienes can
lead to anaphylactic shock which is
pretty dangerous right
lastly i will tell you that recent
research
has shown that leukotriene inhibitors
could be
very useful for patients who are
suffering from late stage of alzheimer's
disease
and dementia clinical trials has shown
that
administrating these kind of inhibitors
might improve
the memory loss so in this video in
short we have learned many things we
learned the leukotriene biosynthesis
pathway
we looked at the involvement of
leukotriene in disease
we also looked at how leukotriene
signaling works at cellular and
molecular level
so i hope you enjoyed this video if you
find this video useful please
don't forget to like share and subscribe
you can also support me in patreon
and if you want to take my course in
academy which is india's biggest
learning platform
you can use my code ap10 to get a 10
discount
and do let me know in the comments how
you like my videos your comment
is my motivation so see you next time in
the next video thank you